we got ahold of Dale jr. yesterday he's
in Las Vegas retirement the awards
ceremony there and we talked about a
wide variety of things but Dale
Earnhardt jr. joining us in the first
thing I asked him was how's retirement
it's going great it's only been a few
days but it's hard to tell really what
my future is gonna look like as far as
my schedule you know I've always had
with racing of you know I could plan my
schedule out 610 months in advance I
knew exactly where I was gonna be every
weekend and what I needed to be doing
and with moving into the broadcast booth
I have no idea what the first six months
the year is gonna look like I know I'm
gonna be preparing a lot for that job
and I'm gonna make myself available to
that as I can because I think I need to
be I know as green as I am to
broadcasting I got so much to learn but
I have no idea of what I'm gonna be
doing my time hopefully it's gonna be
fun and we've got some exciting ideas
and I'm gonna rest a little bit
hopefully in December and January a
little time to take it easy and then we
got the baby coming in May and hopefully
that you know that month I could spend a
lot of time helping Amy with that you
got names picked out
we do we started a list on our phones
that we share and I had a lot of names
that I liked but all those guys sent a
trash can and I was on Jimmy Kimmel show
a couple days ago and I said man you
know I was really surprised that I don't
have I don't you know I really wanted to
be involved in picking a name but I
guess it's really up to her and he said
well you could carry the baby if he
wanted to name it I'm learning as I go
that that's really gonna be down to her
but she's got some great ideas and and
whatever she chooses is gonna be just
perfect all right if it was a boy and
you had to name it after a NASCAR driver
current NASCAR driver my gosh
oh man that's a tough - that's a tough
call Kyle Larson's a cool name I think
chase Elliott that's a cool name and
Ryan Blaney I mean all these young kids
are coming in with all these racy names
I like it so yeah I think chase Blaney
chase Blaney come I don't know you know
how much speed whoo speed speed earner
yeah okay speed Earnhardt I like that
well then you tell Amy you get to name
the girl and I get to name the boy yeah
well the thing is is that when you know
when we got married we were already
talking about names and we've had the
boys name for two years so that was
really easy and we did we couldn't come
we couldn't come up with a girl's name
we still kind of still were still
working on that what are you gonna miss
the most I'm gonna miss my team you know
it's like think it's like those guys
there with the show helping you I mean
that's your boys you know and you know
y'all work and fight together every day
and try to put together the best show
you can every day and those will be the
people that you miss the most when all
this is over and so I'm gonna miss all
the mechanics the road guys that I've
worked with some of them I've worked
with for five six years straight and in
those moments when you're racing and
practicing together you'll never be able
to recreate that and intensity and that
butter that bond and Brotherhood that
you have so I'm gonna miss I'm gonna
miss them because they're great people
they're great friends I mean I'll still
have those relationships and be able to
see them but not quite as often and we
won't be able to go to battle together
like we used to I miss those moments of
working together with those guys what
won't you miss I won't miss the drivers
meetings they were always kind of more
of a show than anything when the drivers
meeting when I was a kid and I'd get to
go to drivers meeting it was only the
drivers in the building that were just
the drivers and so there's a lot of
communication between the drivers and
the officials and the drivers meetings
turned into more of a spectacle where
it's a bit of a show for all there's a
tons of fans and CEOs of companies and
it's more
it's less about the instructions you're
getting about the race then more about
introducing everybody and playing a lot
of loud music and you know that it's
kind of a more of a send-off for the
drivers than anything and there's
definitely no communication from the
drivers to the officials anymore because
no the drivers drivers were no too
nervous to speak up and all those people
in there but there's a couple of things
that I won't miss but for the most part
as it's funny I hated testing I hated I
didn't like practicing that much I
really did I hated traveling and being
away from home I didn't like really much
about driving race cars or being in the
sport when I started and at that time I
got to the final season all the things
that I didn't like I love yeah I was
like what has happened to me I've loved
I loved practicing I want to go test
with the guys I want to be your you know
yours yours you're counting down those
final races and getting into that last
season you start to realize like this
stuff not all that bad it's actually a
lot of fun in the relationships and
stuff that you have make it that much
better so I enjoyed the travel I started
cycling with with Jimmie Johnson and and
Matt Kenseth and Daniel Suarez and
there's a whole bunch of drivers that
were cycling and we'd go ride every
Friday between practice and qualifying
so I was getting outside the racetrack
and seeing all these areas that were
going to erase that that I'd never been
to before I've been to Kansas hundred
times to race never been outside the
racetrack
never saw anything five miles down down
the road and we're going out and riding
30 40 miles and seeing how incredible
this country is you know and how
beautiful it is so I wish I'd have
picked that up or took the initiative to
do that sooner in my career it's
definitely a lot more enjoyable I was a
bit of a hermit and introverted stayed
in the bus and wouldn't go anywhere I
wouldn't go to dinner I'd always just
hang out a bus play video games and cook
and eat there and why I missed out on I
just you know I was like I don't need to
leave the track why should I leave the
track what if something happens what if
I'm needed to be there what if I just
couldn't
I just couldn't imagine why you would
want to leave the track I need to leave
the track I know it sounds silly but but
were you too famous though that you
couldn't know yourself no no it was
nothing to do with that I was just I
just didn't think going outside the
track was enjoyable I wanted to be in
the bus just hanging out and once I met
and once I met Amy and she's like I
can't sit in here all weekend crazy
we're going to eat I'm like oh man this
sucks I don't wanna go eat and so we're
you know I start going out and and in
enter and enjoying you know take I just
felt like I couldn't release from being
at the track and being a driver and
focusing on the car and practicing I
feel like I couldn't loosen my grip on
that and if I drove out of the track for
a dinner somewhere down the street that
was me being you know being too carefree
I just wasn't comfortable with that but
she showed me how to enjoy myself and
still you know be a race car driver and
it's happened late in my career and that
this last season was what we're probably
least stressful of all of them because I
you know I wasn't
up in that bus or hanging out in the
holler all day just kind of chewing my
fingernails and wondering about what's
next on the race car but do you think
that people would have viewed that as
you weren't taking it as serious as you
should or in your mind you're saying I
you know if I get outside of here then
I'm losing focus on what I'm supposed to
be doing as a driver well that's what I
guess that's kind of what I felt I felt
like that I had to be inside the track
at all times the moment I got there on
the weekend till I left after the race
that I couldn't leave the track I just
felt like but what if something happened
what if I was needed to be there even in
the middle of the night I don't really
know what that's about but that was just
me as a as an introvert if anybody knows
you know what being an introvert like
you just you just kind of buckle
yourself down in a shell and you're not
very social and you kind of socially
awkward in a lot of situations to be
honest with you and so you avoid those
up you know those opportunities and I
was really shy and wasn't comfortable
going out on my own and interacting and
socially interacting up you know after a
few beers or something somewhere I would
loosen up but you
it was it was until I met Amy that sort
I got that confidence and got more
comfortable kinda in my own skin and
definitely loosen up a little bit and
started to enjoy myself did you ever go
to therapy oh yeah I mean I've been in
therapy in and out of my and out of my
whole life I mean I was in therapy as a
child and definitely think that therapy
is useful a very useful tool if you meet
the right therapist mm-hmm I met a lady
named Jane that I've worked with on and
off over the last several years and she
has changed my life you know it's and if
you meet the right person that you can
trust and you listen and will and sort
of absorb what they're telling you it
can be incredibly helpful so but as the
trial Channel that's that's different
yeah I think it was different as a child
it was hard to open up and understand
why you were there I was going on or
what the what was the reason for being
there but I mean I was a troubled kid I
was I got kicked out of a Christian
school or was gonna get kicked out of a
Christian school I got sent to military
school for a year and a half and and I
didn't really I didn't really have much
direction you know till I got
opportunity to drive race cars and was
really probably more of a disappointment
I think than anything up until probably
around 1996-97 when I started driving an
Infiniti series for a couple races for
dad and started showing hey there's some
there's some purpose for me here and
here's some direction for me but as a
child I was you know cut having divorced
parents and then the fire we were living
with my mom in a mill house and their
Concord meals Kannapolis that caught
fire when I was five six years old so
I'm standing outside in the yard in the
morning watching our house burned down
my mom is broke and doesn't have I mean
she has nowhere to turn so she had to
move back to Norfolk Virginia to live
with her mother because that's the only
place she could go and she gave she made
a very difficult choice to give up
custody of me and my sister at that
moment to my dad because she knew that
he could provide for us and give us this
better
and so I move I was at my mom's watching
her house burned down in the morning and
then that evening I was at my dad's
house rummaging through my toy box in
the garage seeing if all my toys had
made the trip and that was a that was a
that's difficult so uh yeah probably
needed some therapy through all that
what you dad think of all this of the
like growing up in custody of the kids
no no no being like you were you were
angry or revolting against something
yeah I was just wanting his attention I
was just doing me I didn't know it cuz I
didn't really want his attention not in
a negative way I didn't want you know
whooping zhh and all that stuff but I I
think my sister says that I was always
kind of acting out and trying to get his
attention
Kelly would do things like get good
grades and I was doing whatever I could
to I mean I felt like the only way I
could get him to talk to me or notice me
was if I did something wrong or rebelled
and and fought back or whatever made
things difficult I don't think I did
those things on purpose but my sister
swears I did but you know he was hardly
he wasn't around it wasn't like we were
you know interacting all the time you he
would come home for he would work in a
shop all day long and then he would
drive home and get get to the house
around 9:00 10:00 o'clock it's time for
us to go to bed you know and we're dying
for just five minutes of his time you
know we just want just five minutes just
to see him and say hey and he would come
in and sit in his lazy boy in the living
room and you would sit on the couch and
ask him questions and he would not even
answer your questions I mean he was so
tired and wore down and so much on his
mind about his racing career this is
back in the mid 80s when he was he was
sort of kind of struggling to find his
you know right to ship so to speak and
it was a difficult time but I think that
he he was really frustrated I think for
a long time with me and what I was you
know who I was going to become and what
kind of kid or what kind of person I was
going to grow up to be and as soon as I
mean it really clicked when we got in
the race car and
started he said hey I don't know if he
thought I could drive a racecar not
because he never saw me race in the late
model series from 92 to 96 he never saw
a race
I ran 159 late-model races I don't think
he saw one of them he was just going off
of people's opinions that he you know of
whether I had any talent or not but once
I got an Xfinity car we went to Michigan
and ran in the top 10 and right there in
front of him and it was uh you know he
said hey this is all right so he started
talking about the future will continue
with Dale Junior's I told you went down
a road I didn't think we were going down
talking about therapy and imagine you're
five years old you're watching your
mom's house burned down and next thing
you know your mom is giving you back to
your father trying to figure all that
out and going into therapy and your dad
doesn't see you race doesn't know if you
can race you're acting out he got a
famous dad and just trying to find
yourself so as I said when we started
the interview he's as honest as anybody
I think we've ever had here proud to
know him
we'll come back part two I talked to him
about if he didn't get into racing what
would he have done and would he consider
being the president of NASCAR Dale jr.
part two coming up we were only going to
talk ten minutes and I think we talked
twenty-one minutes but spent a lot of
time talking about being in therapy
talking about his father a lack of a
relationship he acted out he just wanted
to be noticed his dad didn't even know
if he could race cars but he's come a
long way
age 43 with a baby on the way now
retiring gonna work for NBC with their
coverage of NASCAR and I started out
part two of the interview by asking him
if he didn't get into racing what would
he be doing I was working at my dad's
dealership is a service mechanic I was
changing oil so they had had a deal
where you could get a it was this twenty
nine minutes or less quick lube where
you got the oil changed and ever pretty
much everything in your car looked at
good good six thousand or three thousand
mile service on your car and I was the
only mechanic in there doing those
I did that for a couple years I worked
with the assistant engine guy pulling
like I said he had an engine job or a
transmission job to do I pulled the
[ __ ] or I pulled the broke engine and
then he put the new stuff in and I went
to a Technical College and got an
automotive degree in Statesville North
Carolina and so that's what I was doing
and it was fun you know I really enjoyed
it it took a lot of pride in it I kept
my stuff clean um you know you saved
your money the tool man would come once
a week and you'd want this new cool tool
and I was right there in the middle of
the Christmas parties and all that I
mean it's just a normal life you know
and that's what I didn't think racing
was going to work because like I said I
ran those 159 late-model races only won
three of them I ran into top five a lot
but I just wasn't winning enough races
that I thought that I would get an
opportunity but beyond that and the
money was drying up we we run out of
money to run our late-model car in 1997
we only ran eight races dad just point
Blake told me he said we don't have any
more money I'm not paying for this so we
had a sponsor and that went away and
when it was come down him paying for
paying for it himself he wasn't willing
to do that so we only ran a couple races
and lucky enough that same year I got an
opportunity to an Xfinity car the Busch
Series at the time to to run and ran
well enough to get the chance to drive
the car full time in 1998 but I think if
I was at racing I'd be a mechanic in
either automotive dealerships or I might
be a mechanic on the road and for a race
team you know who's to say I wouldn't be
working in Motorsports as a mechanic or
a road crew would you want to be the
president of NASCAR down the road what I
want to be I don't really know I mean
it's not as easy to fix you know a lot
of the it's not as easy to come up with
a solution for everything a lot of
people have opinions about you know
things that's going on is Ford and and
the sports in a really good place in my
opinion personally but everybody has
opinions on what could be different it's
not really easy to come up with those
solutions and the other side of that too
is is that no matter what you come up
with people we're going to bash it or
somebody you know something to love it
something to hate it you know you're
never going to
you're never gonna win but you know
there's yeah I think it would be
interesting to know to be in those
conversations to be in those boardroom
meetings to understand a little bit more
about what's going on and how does you
know how they come to decisions that
they come to and I'm sure you know
there's a lot more moving parts than
myself and a lot of people know that
make up the decisions they have so is
that a yes sir in the mind that's I
don't think I would want to be a
president of NASCAR nor do I think I
would be a great president for the sport
I think that I could be just underneath
that and maybe a Mike Helton style role
or a Steve O'Donnell style role where
you know I have some influence but
there's you know I think the France
family should and always should be the
you know the leaders of the sport I mean
they they're the ones who brought
brought brought this together and
created it but I think that it would be
fun and and I do believe I could you
know it would be something I would be
good at if I could be an influence in
the sports some way somehow I think you
should take the RV take the family and
just go around to Redskins games next
year I mean why not that sounds like a
lot of fun I mean are better they are
they are more fun to watch these last
couple of years as the defense has
gotten better but I don't know you know
it's funny I get invited to go see them
play away but I don't feel comfortable
what is that about I don't feel
comfortable going into the opponent's
Stadium stadium yeah I don't feel
comfortable doing that up like when they
go if they play the Panthers I don't or
Cowboys especially I cannot go to
Cowboys Stadium do you hate the Cowboys
I don't like them yes do you hate them
just don't work yeah sure I mean I don't
we played them this weekend so yeah it's
a game it's a must-win I grew up in a
family that had you know a lot of
cowboys fans in it and it's been it's
been a tug of war all my life and so
yeah I want them to win be Dallas that
beating Dallas is probably the most
important thing is a season to be honest
with you yeah we're
so what happens in all the other games
either got to be got to be gal Dallas
two times they play them but it's been
they've been playing pretty good man I
mean this injuries gashed it seems like
this year there's like three times or
four times more injuries across the leak
especially the Redskins man they've lost
a lot you guys I mean their injury
they're our list looks like a starting
lineup it's just been very difficult for
the team but they played well even
despite the injuries they've had all
right final question it's a serious one
more surprising that you're retiring
your Tony Stewart's engaged I think
that's right surprises Tony Stewart's
engaged and the fact that he's riding a
bike he's cycling now I I didn't know
that you could get that body into
bicycle shorts I didn't either I was I
mean everybody just assumed it was
Photoshop but it's real it's a real
photo and I've talked to him personally
and he has admitted that he has taken up
cycling because he's trying to get
himself in better shape and I think that
this whole engagement and this woman in
his life is obviously having a positive
effect on him so it's gonna be exciting
hopefully you know like hopefully
there's you know kids in their future
and all that good stuff I would love
this I think everyone offices would love
to see how that thanks Dali going down
the road yeah I got to hang out with him
last night so he's in great he's in
great shape and and he's mentally and
not physically why isn't no no I think
he's actually getting in better shape
physically he's riding this bike
he's pretty committed to things like
that I mean when he takes something up
like that he's not gonna get in that
spandex just try it out he's in I think
he's bought in yeah I thought when you
said that you were hanging out with him
you were talking about his belly hanging
out I thought that that was kind of mean
spirited but that's that's not true
right okay hey Junior have fun tonight
and thank you we appreciate your time
okay so that's how the interview ended
they're pulling him out the door we were
only supposed to go ten minutes and that
was the the PR person jumping in there
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel two three
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]